a replica of the statue of liberty
stands tall and proud in front of their
hotel
each time ahmad and his family go for a
walk they go past lady liberty
but to them it doesn't symbolize freedom
the statue stands for everything we've
lost
freedom everything we hoped for and last
in afghanistan
ahmad is not his real name
the family don't want their identity to
be revealed out of fear for their loved
ones in afghanistan
and we're only allowed to film them from
the back like with nearly all refugees
here
they remain deeply afraid of the taliban
american soldiers saved them at the last
minute
we were evacuated at night
the americans called us and asked for
photos so they could identify families
at the airport
they said they needed for us to board
the plane
so i sent them the photos at 11 in the
evening
they left that same night they spent 25
hours waiting outside the airport along
with thousands of other would-be
refugees all fearing for their lives
when they finally entered the airport
they heard a huge explosion
a suicide attack took the lives of 180
people
they waited for more than two days to
board a plane
now they stand in line for food three
times a day in a resort hotel on the
albanian coast
international aid groups mainly from the
us and the uk cover the food and lodging
ahmad's wife lena even attends english
classes three times a week compared to
many refugee shelters it's luxurious
but the residents here are plagued with
uncertainty
most of them were relatively well off in
afghanistan they're educated and
cosmopolitan
now they want to reach the us and build
a new future there but they've been
stranded here for two months
we have good living conditions here but
most of us are in limbo we want to
settle down somewhere as quickly as
possible
[Music]
ahmad was a high-ranking staff member in
the government and he studied in the us
now he hopes the americans will keep
their promise and quickly grant him and
his family asylum he's trying to stay
positive
[Music]
we don't know what the status of our
applications for asylum is
but hard work is going into them
and the delegation from the u.s congress
came to visit here which certainly says
a lot
they're working on our cases and we
won't be forgotten
it sounds good but with each day that
passes their uncertainty grows and the
american aid organization looking after
ahmad's group has its hands tied
we are supporting them here in albania
but we are not their visa sponsors um
i know that uh
of course the overwhelming concern is
about being forgotten here in albania um
and and
being forgotten by the us government
here
on the albanian side the foreign
ministry is in charge of their cases but
no one here knows when the asylum
seekers will be accepted elsewhere
either
right now they're um we're taking all
the measures and we'll we're helping
while they uh it's transitory for some
of them that are um
going to embark and leave uh to the us
but of course if any of them would like
to make albania their home that is also
open and on the table but at the time
we're working on
with the visa process to for them to
leave the country
until then they will remain stuck in
their four-star resort home but the
seaside is at least a new experience for
them
we go on walks here in the morning it's
nice and so is the fresh breeze it's
really nice
the replica of the statue of liberty
shines in the dark in front of the hotel
but the refugees are still waiting for
their american dream to come true